okay what do you think happens when we
combine a wedding day wedding talk and a
bunch of Wellness product plugs well
probably now the infamous fit Fatale
wedding diet hey everyone I'm Abby sharp
welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
before we get into it today I want to
let everyone know that I will be
discussing disorder eating and eating
disorders and restrictive diets so
please feel free to skip this video if
it doesn't feel supportive to you also
if you're new here please subscribe to
the channel we love to see more of you
join the community and if you're ever
looking for more healthy meal ideas hit
up the description for my free new
Hunger crushing combo ebook Okay so
we're gonna do this super casually I
want to catch you guys up so the fifth
they teleposted a video about what she
ate on her wedding day you asked so here
is what I ate on my wedding day and
basically the internet lost their
what the is in my coffee anyways in
case you missed it the Highlight Reel
basically consisted of having two green
smoothies plus a lot of raw vegetables
and a few bites of salad and then having
salad with salmon and more vegetables
for dinner low sugar wine to drink and
finally sugar-free dairy-free
gluten-free cake and a sugar-free candy
bar at the end and you know what if
these Foods bring her Joy on her special
day who are we really to judge I'm
quietly judging you but this then we had
a raid blow pills on every table I don't
know what our friends are like but I do
feel that this move is a little
distasteful pretty presumptive and also
maybe a bit triggering for some guests
like it really makes people
uncomfortably aware of their stomach and
their bodily Sensations on a day that in
my opinion should be about anything
other than that but anyways I digress I
posted my reaction on Tick Tock but I've
since of course had a lot of time to
reflect and as usual your girl has some
thoughts I have some thoughts so first
of all it actually wasn't easy doing
research on this Creator's backstory
because she seemed to have preemptively
blocked me on all of her platforms even
before I responded to her wedding what I
eat in a day which fair but really this
is a bit of a red flag for me that
there's some kind of uncertainty about
the helpfulness or the safety of that
person's messaging obviously your girl
has some workarounds detective detective
and I did see that after the initial
backlash she then posted several
follow-up videos in defense so in one of
those she shared what she served her
guests which addressed the pushback that
she was getting about limiting her
guests to all these sugar-free Foods all
day and that was definitely relieved
because I know that if I only ate
veggies and a bit of salmon and then
sugar-free Cake and Candy no amount of
anti-blote pills would save my gut I'm a
little bit bloated she also posted a
video responding to the comment
LMFAO I cannot imagine having an Eden
sorter themed wedding basically in this
video she first called out bullies for
making all these cruel comments and then
pivoted back to her messaging around
food intolerances and inflammation we
need to do better educating our
communities about this severity around
chronic gut issues allergies and
intolerances and the long-term impact
inflammation and stress have on the body
and disease so a quick few thoughts on
this one agreed never cool to laugh and
exclaim that someone has an ed all in
the same sentence or even to explicitly
accuse anyone of having an ed like that
is between the individual and their
health care team period but two I think
there's actually a lot of education on
the internet right now about gut issues
and inflammation probably more than we
actually need because unfortunately it's
largely very sensationalized and
anecdotal not evidence-based and
typically does way more harm than good
by causing all of this undue food fear
around perfectly safe nourishing food
like I really wish that influencers
would share what they mean when they
throw around the term inflammation
because I find that most people online
use the term quite clumsily to describe
looking like puffy or not having a flat
stomach or feeling bloated when
medically it's actually referring to an
acute or chronic reaction in the body to
an irritant or an intruder which could
be anything from like a splinter in your
finger or chronic lung damage from
smoking now inflammation could also be
in response to a food allergy which may
be true for her but a lot of cases the
long-term risk that she's talking about
has much more to do with the irritant
itself rather than the side effects of
inflammation like looking puffy or
bloated but moving on she also posted
another follow-up video talking about
respecting people's food choices based
on what works best for them take a
listen expecting what feels good to our
bodies for the purpose of feeling
energized and present is not diet
culture to me seeing someone Embrace
what works for their individual body is
really inspirational but to many it is
uncomfortable out of societal norms and
for foreign it really shouldn't matter
if it's a personal choice to limit
something like inflammation something
that personally has been extremely
crippling on my mental and physical
health or if it's doctor recommended to
manage a disease for making the choices
to feel good for your body we as a
society should be respecting that end of
story okay let's unpack this one
together 100 I believe in body autonomy
which means if you have decided that you
don't ever want to eat sugar ever again
for whatever reason even it's because
you believe like a teaspoon of sugar is
going to grow a sugar tree in your belly
like cool it's your life I talk a lot
about the importance of collecting data
and listening to your body on what feels
good and what doesn't feel good and if
not having a lick of any real sugar on
your wedding day works for you
great but I just want to remind everyone
that health is not just the absence of
disease or absence of bloating in this
case and part of collecting data also
means asking yourself some really hard
questions about how these restrictions
affect not just our physical health but
also our mental emotional and social
well-being as well like sure you may
feel physically great but at what
expense in a lot of cases this deep dive
can be really really hard to do okay now
before I say what I'm going to say I
want to be clear that I am not
diagnosing this creator with an ed this
wedding diet made such a splash on the
internet because it clearly triggered a
lot of people who believed they saw a
restrictive and potentially disordered
message being shared to the masses
especially in the context of the rest of
Sam's content where for example she
often talks about her 80 20 rule
where 80 percent are foods in their full
natural state
and the 20 are still fully Dairy gluten
and sugar-free but she may allow a
little bit more processing the 80 in my
80 20 eating is about eating food in
their natural state so grains veggies
fruit fish meat nuts seeds all of that
stuff that comes from the earth that is
unaltered so that twenty percent that
y'all are always looking for is not
necessarily going to look like chips and
cookies for me because I eat dairy
substitutes a lot of the times that
looks like fake cheese or other
processed things that I add into sauces
or what I eat in a day and it's
important to understand that eating
modified food that has preservatives and
chemicals can be a lot worse for you
than just eating a cookie that has whole
grains and dark chocolate now again I do
not care how another person eats or how
they want to Define healthy or like 80
20.
but as I always say us content creators
have a lot of responsibility and
creating fear around nutritious
accessible foods that are modified or
processed in any way and like painting
them all as mere chemicals is elitist at
best and dangerous at worst that said
while I take issue with some of the
messaging to the masses everyone's on
their own food and body journey and I
don't think it's an excuse to bully or
call anyone out as having an eating
disorder online so yes I will always
call out problematic content that I see
here on Tick Tock or YouTube or
Instagram in an effort to help dispel
misinformation but I want to make it
very clear that I am not diagnosing or
directing this education about eating
disorders at this Creator okay so to put
it back on me for a moment for those of
you who do not know my story I had a
pretty severe eating disorder in my late
teens and early 20s and it really did
start out as an innocent quest to feel
better after suffering from chronic gut
issues so I basically convinced myself
that I needed to cut out all sugar
because it was inflammatory and that I
needed to only eat clean foods to heal
my gut clean food please
and when people would tell me oh just
have a taste it's fine I would justify
this absolute restriction and abstinence
by telling people that I was allergic or
intolerant or just that the bad foods
made me feel sick so I know firsthand
how manipulative an eating disorder
voice can be because now looking back I
know that having a little sugar in the
context of a healthy diet wouldn't have
caused any adverse effects I was
probably just afraid of completely
losing control and this is what
orthorexia does and if this is a new
term for you orthorexia is often
described as an eating disorder where
clean eating is taken to an extreme
today you will eat clean healthy foods
so really it's a fixation with the
quality of food rather than the quantity
as we often see with like anorexia
though sometimes these things can
absolutely overlap orthorexia is really
hard to diagnose because the diagnostic
tools that we do have are either not
validated or not very specific but to
give you an idea the Bratman Knight
criteria includes questions like do you
spend over three hours a day thinking
about or planning and or preparing clean
food do you have a feeling of
superiority to those who do not follow
the same dietary principles that you
have a very strict and rigidly followed
diet with any kind of compensatory
deprivation if you slip up or mess up is
this idea of Clean Eating Central to
your life and does it displace other
relationships or hobbies that don't
align with these values is a food's
nutritional value more important than
how you enjoy it or your pleasure that
you get out of it do you get a sense of
self-worth by sticking to your diet and
does the diet affect any of your Social
or psychosocial relationships again it's
really hard to diagnose orthorexia
because it can be so sneaky and
persuasive but we tend to see the
crossover from like a normal Health
promoting Behavior to an end disorder
when the behaviors or thoughts interrupt
your ability to live a life that's
aligned with your values but the problem
is in disorders often trick us into
believing they're aligned with our
values because the Ed behaviors make us
feel kind of like safe we also often
find all these workarounds like hanging
out with friends who also share a
restrictive lifestyle or like convincing
ourselves that we just don't like bread
or cheese or sweet things I did all
these things I once told my dietitian
that I just prefer fat-free cheese the
lie detector determined that was a lie
that was 100 my Ed talking truly
listening to our body becomes merely
impossible when an Edie is at play
because the Edie voice often overrides
RNA cues the other piece that I think is
worth talking about is the Vicious Cycle
that is gut issues and restrictive
eating so I've discussed this in a lot
more detail in my video here but there
is a strong correlation between
disordered eating and bloating or other
IBS symptoms for a variety of reasons so
one under eating can reduce stomach acid
production and serotonin levels and
literally starve our digestive organs
which essentially reduces gut motility
and causes all sorts of symptoms like
bloating gas IBS Etc so consuming a lot
of fiber via excess veggies as well as
sugar alcohols or sweeteners via like
sugar-free or diet foods can also cause
a lot of severe bloating and gas another
really important piece here is the gut
brain access so research suggest that
folks with eating disorders often have
mental health traits like anxiety or OCD
which then predict functional gut
disorders like IBS bloating and
constipation and I think another one
that I see really often is the role of
Extreme Elimination diets so again this
often begins with really good intentions
so maybe you have some bloating so you
cut out a bunch of foods or food groups
and you feel better because you've
eliminated a ton of potential triggers
keyword potential potential lots of
potential yes and then when you do have
so much as like a lick of ice cream you
feel horrible and that just confirms
that you can never ever ever again have
any of these bad foods again
physiologically this all makes sense
because when you stop eating dairy for
example your body down regulates the
enzymes that we need to break it down so
the first time you cheat it's like
debilitating overwhelming and
debilitating for me and then all the
together is like this horrible vicious
cycle the Restriction causes functional
gut disorders which increase the fear of
foods which increases anxiety which
increases the bloating so we eat less
out of fear and then it just kind of
blows out of control the next thing you
know you've got like 10 safe foods and
your whole life is revolving around
surveilling all these Body Sensations to
summarize my thoughts here food
intolerances and gut issues are no joke
but often cutting out multiple Foods or
food groups can do more harm than good
both physically and emotionally and it
often requires taking a step back to
objectively evaluate how your diet
affects your overall quality of life and
your social relationships and just the
space you have left in your life or your
brain for thinking about things other
than clean food so we really need to do
the work to determine if an extreme
level of restriction is truly an act of
self-care and honestly only you can
answer that question I can't answer that
that definitely user
657345 cannot answer that question but I
hope this video was eye-opening for you
guys I really think this is an important
conversation and one that is often
missed in the online Wellness Community
but I'd love to hear your thoughts below
don't forget to hit up the description
if you guys want a copy of my free
Hunger crushing combo ebook subscribe to
this Channel and I will see you next
time on Abby's kitchen bye